[Music]
[Applause]
good morning from the plaza de la armería
of the royal palace in madrid attend the
state tribute to the  victims of the
corona virus disease and of
recognition to society this
place today becomes a space of support
for those who suffer in memory of those who
died and of gratitude to those who have
given everything for others it will be a day that
will always remain in  our memory
[Music]
with any agenda with a victim and their
in doubt how is your heart is maybe
it would make you icing ccoo there is ekitaldia cake
on the shoulder of ariza that lasts gold and they
shake the baton that was tuco denied
anything
good day from the palau  royal to madrid
state food assistance for
victims of coronavirus and estimated
reconnection test in society a day
that will forever be etched in
our memory
two days of the royal palace in madrid
attend a state tribute  to the
victims of coronavirus and
recognition to society a day that
will be recorded in our memory
with morning wonder world college of
madrid
jordan ding of this moment of dictating
mercal branding before the expansion of
disney bolt forever in serious in almería
but paraguay ar de madrid  do not participate
national aromas with judith indicated no one
sees the shoulders of the 7 south gesture to
yamaha fetus I have not died
since last December more than
13 million people have been infected
with coronavirus worldwide and almost
600,000 have lost their  life fernando
fernández calleja lost his brother the
journalist josé maría calleja who died
in madrid on april 21 his loss
this morning joins the pain of the entire country
for those who died alone those who
died in hospitals in their homes
in nursing homes  today hernando remembers
his brother and his mouth the memory of
all the others
i
lucía bosé
was a famous actress died for food
enrique múgica was  minister and ombudsman
died for kobe
luís sepúlveda was a successful writer
based in asturias
died for cobista
josep maría benet and jornet
was a well-known catalan playwright
died for koi
alfonso Cortina was a businessman died for
kobe
jose luis capón a legend of atletico
de  madrid
died for kobe
josé maría calleja
was a great writer and journalist he died
for food
but today i prefer to simply say
that josemaría was my brother because today
we are not here to honor the glories
of anyone but to honor the
naked memory of those who left brutally
in these  months of pandemic
we are here to honor all
those silent anonymous dead
who lost their lives as a result of
the terrible disease
that is why I know that when I talk about my
brother I am talking about all of them and
reminding all
of them of sada who was 28 years old audel  since
he had 102
of jose julian and albacete
of Marino lastras de cuéllar he
left maria q  he was the editor
of consolation he was a farmer
josemaría was the youngest of eight
children and I was lucky enough to take care of him
and tutor him throughout our lives
we maintained a close relationship that went
beyond the relationship between brothers
we were friends we were colleagues and
companions  we were a reference
for each other unconditional support in
the hardest moments and also in the
happiest
josemaria was a brave and
honest man but lakovic never distinguished
between human beings
the best ones the most fighters
also left
and has been and continues to be  still throughout the
world let's not forget a
cruel and destructive cold executioner
I believe that my pain is similar to the pain
of each and every one of the relatives of
the victims I will
remember all the intensity of the
truncated affection for my brother but I will
also remember it I can  assure the thousands
of deceased these months
they were not my brothers I do not know their names I do
not share experiences with them
but they were  my compatriots share
illusions and hopes with them
and to say together with them the same
pain compassion is a feeling
that makes us more human
more than kindness more than love
compassion allows us to understand the
pain of others
their broken desires their sadness  immense,
that is why I want to ask everyone today with
passion,
we are not going to forget any of those who
lost their lives in this painful
moment of our history,
because memory is a duty, it is the
best tribute we can pay them,
staying united in their memory and
building together  the country that they
would have liked to share
[Music]
and today we symbolically say goodbye to
mothers, fathers, sons, brothers, friends,
and taking their hands, we
caress their cheeks, we
kiss their foreheads, we
register in our hearts in their
gaze
[Music],
rest in peace
and remain in the memory of  everyone
in memory of spain
[Applause]
aroa lópez is a supervising nurse
in the emergency department of the hospital in  the
vall d'hebron in barcelona she has not
contracted the virus but more than 50,000
health workers throughout spain' yes and dozens
of them have died
millions of Spaniards dedicated their applause to them every afternoon with
infinite gratitude for what they
gave their best  themselves their dedication
even their lives the heroes of Spanish healthcare
are also the heroes of the
countryside and the sea who fed us
the carriers on the roads the
police and agents of all
the state security forces and bodies the
members of the army  the teachers the
students also all those who
stayed at home who never forgot
the hugs but
those who comforted us in
confinement those who informed us and
all
those who worked and today continue to
work for us on behalf of
everyone today were left without them  Aro speaks to López to
participate in this act today is a
sad privilege today we pay tribute
to the thousands of people who died  ron
because of lakovic 19 during these months
of tireless struggle sharing the
pain of his family and loved
ones
I wish none of this would have happened
I wish I were not here saying
these words
but it is an immense honor to be able to speak on
behalf of my colleagues
the health professionals,
auxiliary medical nurses and physiotherapists,
administrative personnel, kitchen cleaning personnel,
radiodiagnosis, laboratory maintenance and
microbiology, psychology and the rest
of the areas that gave support to the
care providers and not only them, I
also appear on behalf of
what was then called  the first
line carriers restockers cashiers
and shopkeepers energy
and communications workers pharmacists
sanitation personnel
state security forces and bodies it
is impossible to mention them all because there
were thousands of men and
women who cared for them with their work  the
millions  of confined Spaniards
in my years as supervisor
of the emergency service at the
vall d'hebron university hospital I have had
very difficult experiences but this one will
mark us forever it has been very hard
we have felt powerless with a
brutal feeling of uncertainty and the
pressure of having  to learn and decide
on the fly we have given everything we
had we have worked to the limit of
our strength and we have once again
understood perhaps better than ever why
we chose this profession caring for and saving
lives
although many colleagues had to
give their own lives for this
we have covered  basic and emotional needs
we have been messengers of the last goodbye
for elderly people who died alone
listening to the voice of their children through
the telephone we have made video calls
we have shaken hands and we have had
to swallow the tears when someone
told us do not let me die
we have only experienced situations that damage your
soul because who speaks  I was behind the
hippies they were not heroes we were people
who distanced themselves from their families to
protect them from possible contagion
people who left the hospital
loaded with all those emotions and who
returned to our work from
loneliness and exhaustion one day more
willing to transmit  strength and encouragement
to the sick beyond our
own fears
forces transmitted through the
eyes of the looks because it was the only
part of the body that was visible
between us we have learned to
communicate through them looks
that some of us have tattooed on the  skin
looks that have meant so much
paraphrasing the ancient morla group in
their song forbidden hugs for those
who make the verb take care of their flag and
your house and fight so that no one dies
alone
without fearing their fear and using their skin
as a shield for those who  they do
dirty work the most beautiful work in the
world and they paint the darkness blue
I want to thank you co  reason for those
applause that the citizens dedicated to us
and I also want to ask from my heart that they
not forget that,
now respecting the health recommendations
I want them to think of those who
died and also of the
health professionals who gave their
lives in the fight please make your
effort  never be in vain
I also want to ask the
public powers that defend
everyone's health to remember that there is no better
tribute to those who left us than to watch
over our health and guarantee the
dignity of our professions
and that we all answer a simple
question and take care  of us, if the
person who cares for us cannot do so,
let us never forget the lesson
learned, thank you
today, together with hernando and aroa, together with
dozens of relatives of victims and
people who suffered from the disease, is
the head of state of the general courts,
the government  of Spain' the
judiciary the autonomous communities
and local corporations  it is the
constitutional powers that
represent us that pay homage and
recognition to those who deserve it so much,
also senior
European and international representatives whom we
thank for their presence and also that of
the representatives of all
religious confessions with a
white rose in hand are going to  head to
the center of the square where the
flame that remembers all those who
died burns
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
ah
no no
[Music]
sometimes
His Majesty the King now speaks,
Mr. President of the Government,
High National Autonomous
and Local
Authorities, High European and International Authorities,
and Diplomatic Corps,
Dear Relatives of Victims and
Representatives of the Groups that are
Dealing with the COVID-19 Pandemic  the cob and
ladies and gentlemen
thank you all for your presence and
company
lyon
today is a day that we will keep in
our  r memory of
a day that will remain engraved in our
hearts
because today we pay tribute with all due
respect and the greatest solemnity of the state
to the thousands of citizens who have
lost their lives as a result of the
kobe 19 pandemic
and today is also a day that will leave a
mark on  our consciences
because we recognize and praise thousands
of citizens whose conduct has been
the best example of the civic
and moral values of our society and t
e best reason for our collective hope, first
of all I want to remember the decea
ed and c
nvey our deep
orrow to their families  and most sincere consolation
all our affection and the most emotional hug
you are not alone in your pain it
is a pain that we share
your mourning is ours that here is
present before all Spaniards
pain and mourning in which we also all
recognize ourselves
united in the  same
universal principles of humanity and
solidarity
the building of our
democratic coexistence  There are
lives whose vocation for harmony
always invites us to serene reflection
and gratitude,
and other citizens that
we have unfortunately lost were men and women who
had a whole future ahead of them,
so much to do and build, and
that this virus has taken from us, leaving
in their families an immense emptiness in the
soul and a great sorrow in all of society
all of them all the deceased will
remain in our memory we
will never forget them
this act cannot repair the pain of
many families for not having been able to
be by their side  In his last
hours, much less lessen the sadness
of his absence, but to do justice
to his life, to his contribution to our
society, to his memory,
we must also and want to
pay tribute to many other people,
this crisis has put us to the test as a
country and as a  society
but it has also allowed us to verify
the principles that define and
characterize thousands of citizens who
have put their e  effort and their work at the
service of the common good
today we recognize behaviors full of
dedication to others without reservations even
putting one's own life at risk
full of solidarity, courage,
exemplarity and generosity that
have moved us
and that do not make everyone proud
are behaviors  of citizens who have
done much more than fulfill their duty,
these behaviors are not accidental, they
are the result of deep personal convictions
, a deep sense of humanity with
their peers, a firm and
loyal commitment to their profession, they
are the result of responsibility and
will.  of service to others
we owe these people much more
than we can imagine they
have saved many lives we owe them
our health, our safety and the
most essential services for daily life
because they are the ones who, in
such difficult conditions, have sustained the  pulse of
our country
we feel towards all of them towards all
those thousands of people an im
I am grateful and I also believe
that it is time to feel proud
of the responsibility
shown by the Spanish people as a whole
in this hard and difficult time,
many people alone
and many others suffering from the disease
in their homes and entire families have
assumed with great fortitude, self-sacrifice
and discipline, the confinement in their
homes
knowing that their conscious and
committed attitude was fundamental and continues to
be so to combat the pandemic it
has been difficult very difficult
because this situation has added
logical feelings of fear of fear
for health  of family and friends
of concern for the example of the
use of tiredness of depression
of uncertainty
and yet our society has given
in these months a lesson of immense
value
spain has shown its best spirit
because when the years go by and
we remember this time these days
we will also remember that we have given ourselves
an example once again in our  Our
history of civility, maturity,
resistance, commitment to others,
ladies and gentlemen,
without a doubt, we have contracted a
moral obligation and a civic duty,
the moral obligation to recognize,
respect and always remember the dignity
of the deceased and especially the
spirit of that admirable generation of
Spaniards
and the civic duty to preserve and
promote the best values that are the basis
of our society, our c
existence, that
oral debt and that civic duty oblig
and commit us all, let's
put together let's put together all our w
ll, our capacity, all our k
owledge, all our effort and commi
ment to be able to  look to the future
with confidence and hope
and let's do it with respect and
understanding responsibility moral strength
determination in the face of adversity and
the spirit of overcoming of the
Spanish people show us the path to follow
to face and overcome difficulties we will
overcome them
that will be the one without a
doubt  best renewed tribute that we can
offer tomorrow to those who today with
all justice and deservedness
we remember recognize and honor
[Applause]
after the signs and the music
after the words and the flowers
we stand up to observe a minute of
silence for the  that they are no longer and we are
going to approach that silence with the
verses of the poet octavio peace with the
opposite thought in the world
especially at this moment in america
where the suffering from the disease
is now more intense
as well as the background of the music
a note sprouts that while it vibrates grows and
thins until in other music it
falls silent sprouts from the bottom of silence into
another sharp tower sword and rises
and grows and suspends us and as it rises
memories fall hopes the little
lies and the big ones and we want to scream
and  in the throat the scream fades
and we end up in the silence where the
silences fall silent
the minute of silence begins
[Applause]
with the sil  encio and applause as
symbols of loss and hope
ends this act of homage we are
witnesses of this new time of what
is gone and of what will come we will never
forget our memory and
eternal gratitude thank
you owner in an astute gold gure  and as soon as
eta throws me co eskerrak eskerrik asko
mostly day with our cut
and eternal agreement thank
you it is never that we want this day or we
remembered and eternal gratitude thank you
we would never forget the style to another
number in guayaquil
union that had not I took it in  the
trigger and canela messi
[Music]